we foster we usually have a foster
downstairs living downstairs so we
usually have a foster mom with puppies
oh that's awesome i get hungry when they
come
i'm kidding um
it's just an ancestral but
you're right
no i i love that dog so much um but
i just but i do watch like hoarders i've
been watching a lot of hoarders lately
we've been watching yeah don't you love
the show and the worst is when you see a
dog in that environment
like chained up but it's also you know i
mean there's like
19 feet [ __ ] piles of newspapers yeah
yeah yeah yeah i hate that yeah that's
yeah yeah that's not a good i [ __ ]
hate hoarders man yeah me too you do why
uh cause they they're holding on to all
that cool stuff
yeah give me some less fortunate
they're so selfish yeah yeah hanging on
to all those awesome newspapers from the
80s and 90s i saw one yesterday the lady
a lady
her plumbing didn't work 10 years ago so
she decided to
poo
in cups oh good right but in plastic
cups yup and she was just laying around
the house and then over the years they
just fell and they fell into the ground
and with the with the [ __ ] rat [ __ ]
and with all the dog [ __ ] too because
she had a dog right that it piled up and
now it's like a six foot high
floor of just fossilized she falls like
[ __ ] so they had to take shovels
like it's ice and crack it you're right
but meanwhile the dog is chained to a
[ __ ] wall what's that face it's gross
what do you mean what's that
that's the most disgusting [ __ ] what's
that face i'm just talking about a six
foot wall of [ __ ]
what's that face yeah don't do the face
yeah don't do that yeah yeah
but
why don't like hoarders is they're still
in denial what's wrong yeah no
everything's fine yeah it's very
specific mental illness yeah yeah and
they just never but i don't i'll never
get it you know heroin i get don't you
i mean
yeah way more than hoarding it's like
yeah yeah yeah you get to just kind of
check out and
lay around and there's all that that
cool iggy pop music and you're in
ireland yeah friends with [ __ ] yeah you
have leather jackets yeah you got no
shirt on you and you and bremner
if you're in the uh if you're you and
mcgregor yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and the other guy yeah
yeah i get i get drugs and uncles you
know it makes you feel
just instantaneously absolutely right
yeah but hoarding like you know human
[ __ ] is you know i don't know yeah
there's no yeah i don't think it's the
same kind of addiction what that's rich
of you
what you're the poo master i am a poo
master oh he loves poo yeah we're all
poo masters in our own way yeah but she
said the puma
i know like those are the grand masters
like i'm a highlander like the only one
yeah um you're like blade i'm bl thank
you poop lady yeah i'm poop blade um i
think we're all poo masters we've all
been doing it for a very long time yeah
it happens whether you like it or not
yeah at least she [ __ ] in a cup you you
bare-assed it on your back seat
all right now we're going to get there
whatever
no is this what you're talking about
what is this is this the lady who's
scooping poop no they're all like this
every episode like that she's scooping
yeah yeah that's what they do he's
trying to clean it up though at least
i what i do is i take the poo from one
[Laughter]
i get a home depot bucket and i haul it
through and sometimes i spill it yeah
and then that means there's more poo and
i just can't figure out where to put it
we're watching a woman just scatter poo
around you yeah yeah
oh oh yeah yeah yeah well i mean uh
bless us all you know i think in this
specific as i've seen i've seen them all
right she had
you know
hundreds of cats
right so they would lift up on the couch
right and they'd just be skeleton
remains of cats oh my god yeah anyway
why don't you start a new podcast it's
the face bro
again not with the [ __ ] face george
you should uh you should start a podcast
called pooblade where you just break
down every episode of hoarders
i would listen to the [ __ ] out of that
yeah and i pooed in my car
three times in my life
in the new car you i'll never
poo in the new car
i'd rather [ __ ]
in on the streets than poo in my new car
have you ever attempted to bare hand it
at least no because my mine's not
let's just say it's not so lady
i pooped myself once in my car where uh
not too long ago probably just just a
handful of years ago
in my driveway i just couldn't even get
up my driveway you were coming home or
leaving i was coming home in a hurry
because i was like
yeah and then was driving up the
driveway and i filled my shorts with poo
poo oh but it was like kind of like it
was the consistency of uh
of like like um
i would say
wet cement that had been out for an hour
like it all stayed where it was supposed
to yeah it didn't even stay in the seat
this is a great time i'm glad to see you
again
but just my last note my last note right
it's not the shame of the poo right that
gets to me right it's the warmth of it
oh right the feeling and then when it's
there for it starts to turn cold
anyway
a little side note if i was a nurse
charting your um driveway poo we'd call
that a formed poo a form poo yeah formed
uh yeah bobby's are
a borderline not formed
yeah no this was uh
i was fortunate because i've had all
kinds were you with molly though at the
time no no but she was home
oh okay uh did you tell her about it
right then and there or did you yeah
right away i walked into the she was in
the den and i walked in without any
clothes on go go and you'll never guess
what
i thought i heard you in the backyard
did you turn the hose on i'm like yes i
did
and uh no but i was winning winnie the
pooh at donald ducking it i had a shirt
on but just everything was like i got to
take a shower i'll talk to you later but
i got the rest of it off outside
anyway yeah
would did would you do it in the
pandemic
what i do yeah i mean were you in canada
were here no i was here we were here in
the castle
in the in my home uh have you been to
his house
it looks like a castle
like like old school harry potter castle
it's beautiful it's an evil it's an evil
it's an evil castle it's a great house
and i remember
this is back in the day when
this is i don't know we talked about
this